[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis guten abend und herzlich
willkommen sie wollen wissen was im
sport passiert ist norbert lehmann
bringt sie auf den neuesten stand
legen wir auf unsere großen themen heute
scholz erste regierungserklärung der
neue kanzler zeigt sich besonders beim
thema corona kämpferisch
razzia nach morddrohungen gegen sachsens
ministerpräsidenten bei
hausdurchsuchungen findet die polizei
waffen und armbrüste
hat deutschland genug impfstoff um
engpässe im frühjahr zu vermeiden kauft
die bundesregierung zusätzliche dosen
ein
die erste regierungserklärung soll ja so
was wie ein großer aufschlag sein so
sieht's aus das haben wir vor heute gab
es die erste vom neuen kanzler scholz
thematisch ging es von den corona
maßnahmen über die gewalttätigen
proteste dagegen auf die wenn der
sendung auch noch genauer schauen bis
hin zur klimakrise über die rede und die
reaktion der opposition andreas opitz
tasche und redemanuskript erstmal
zwischengeparkt dann geht's auf zum
richtigen platz in seiner ersten
regierungserklärung als kanzler
skizziert olaf scholz wir in den
nächsten jahren politik gestalten will
zu beginn der 20er jahre unseres
jahrhunderts stehen wir vor großen
aufgaben und vor großen veränderungen
wir nehmen die herausforderung unserer
zeit an und wir sind zuversichtlich wir
werden sie bewältigen
fortschritt ist die kernbotschaft der
eineinhalbstündigen rede darin auch dank
und anerkennung für die leistung seiner
vorgängerin
dr merkel hat der bundesrepublik
deutschland 16 jahre lang in
eindrucksvoller weise als
bundeskanzlerin gedient jederzeit
orientiert an der sache und an den
tatsachen klar und deutlich ist scholz
botschaft in sachen corona pandemie
impfen für ihn der entscheidende schritt
aus der krise radikalen gewaltbereiten
corona leugnern sagt er den kampf an wir
werden es uns nicht gefallen lassen dass
eine winzige minderheit von enthemmten
extremisten versucht unserer gesamten
gesellschaft ihrem wild aufzutreten eine
aussage die die afg nicht akzeptieren
will für sie ist scholz jetzt schon der
kanzler der spaltet sie sagen sie seien
auch der kanzler der ungeimpften und
sortieren genau damit die bürger in
brave geimpften und ungeimpften
abweichler die cdu ist enttäuscht von
der regierungserklärung ein politisches
aufbruchsignal sei das nicht gewesen ich
erwarte von einem bundeskanzler in der
ersten regierungserklärung nicht das
eher kleinteilig den koalitionsvertrag
der verliert sondern dass er die großen
linien zeit für die linke fehlt in den
zukunftsplänen vor allem eins soziale
gerechtigkeit
insgesamt geht es nicht das normale
leben immer teurer und teurer wird eben
besonders wenn die löhne nicht
entsprechend stammt seine politischen
pläne hat der neue kanzler hinreichend
dargestellt jetzt muss das ganze auch in
politische ergebnisse umgesetzt werden
nach der regierungserklärung kam es in
mehreren bundestagsausschüssen zur
vorsitzenden war die wohl ziemlich
einmalig sind denn sowohl im wichtigen
innenausschuss als auch in den
ausschüssen für gesundheit und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit fehlen die
afg kandidaten für den vorsitz durch
damit geht berichtet dreimal an diesem
tag eröffnet bundestags-vizepräsident
kubicki ausschuss sitzungen bei denen
die afg hofft ihren jeweiligen
kandidaten für den vorsitz
durchzubekommen insbesondere hier im
mächtigen innenausschuss doch dreimal
fallen afd bewerber durch mit der
verwertung aller drei
ausschussvorsitze
haben wir hier einen bruch mit allen
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten zu
verzeichnen den mann als historisch
bezeichnen muss ich würde davon ausgehen
dass alle mitglieder des
innenausschusses ihre gründe hatten so
abzustimmen und so ist das in der
demokratie wenn man in wahlen keine
mehrheiten bekommt wird man nicht
gewählt ich kann ja jetzt auch überhaupt
nichts demokratie problematisches drin
sehen der innenausschuss kontrolliert
unter anderem auch behörden wie den
inlandsgeheimdienst
gleichzeitig werden teile der fdp vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wohl ein
grund für die ablehnung ein anderer der
konkrete kandidat hess er war zu
erwarten oder ist zu erwarten aufgrund
aus seiner bisherigen tätigkeit dass er
eher spalterisch und hetzerisch in den
letzten monaten und jahren agiert hat
insofern nicht geeignet ist und diesen
ausschuss vorsitz zu übernehmen
zuvor waren auch die af die bewerber um
den vorsitz im ausschuss für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und dem im
pandemie zeiten wichtigen
gesundheitsausschuss durchgefallen ich
hätte das in dieser situation
hochproblematisch gefunden
an dieser stelle eine partei einer
partei das feld zu überlassen die sich
mit corona leutnant gemein macht und die
ihre ihrer erzählung raum verschafft
eigentlich stehen der f3
ausschussvorsitzende zu doch ein recht
auf wahl hat ein einzelner kandidat
nicht es ist juristisches neuland und
nun ein thema für den ältestenrat
theo koll ist das ein zeichen dass sich
die anderen parteien im bundestag jetzt
stärker gegen die afg positionieren
der umgang der anderen partei mit der
afg verändert sich jedenfalls merklich
wird insgesamt scharfkantig an das ganze
ist ja jetzt eher zufällig in den fokus
geraten weil die afg sich den vorsitz
des sicherheitsrelevanten
innenausschusses ausgesucht hatte als
reaktion wurden dann heute gleich alle
afd bewerber um ausschussvorsitze
abgelehnt schon bei den vielen wahl
gegen übrigens um einen bundestagsvize
präsidentin hat die afg immer weniger
stimmen bekommen darin spiegelt sich
meines erachtens die wahrnehmung der afg
als zunehmend extreme reporter im
internen richtungskampf hat der
moderator teil rund um jörg neun jahren
verloren und östliche landesverbände der
afg werden als antreiber hinter der
radikalisierung von corona protesten
gesehen all das führt jetzt in der quasi
ja zweite legislaturperiode bei den
anderen parteien zu einem deutlich
entschieden deren umgang mit der fdp
dank für diese einschätzung theo koll in
berlin
nachdem unsere kollegen vom zdf magazin
frontal in telegramm foren von corona
leugnern auf morddrohungen gegen den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten
kretschmann gestoßen sind gab es heute
in sachsen razzien bei sechs
verdächtigen sie sollen eine schwere
staatsgefährdende gewalttat vorbereitet
haben mehrere waffen wurden
beschlagnahmt
der sächsische innenminister sprach von
einem schlag gegen den rechtsextremismus
franziska wunderlich
insgesamt sechs wohnungen in und um
dresden wurden am morgen von
spezialeinsatzkräften durchsucht die
razzia richtete sich gegen mitglieder
einer telegramm gruppe nachdem in ihren
chat morddrohungen gegen den sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten
auftauchten das zdf magazin frontal
hatte darüber berichtet
wir haben eine woche diese sendung die
ersten tatverdächtigen ermittelt diese
jet gruppe ist wesentlich größer das
können also in der folge noch weitere
maßnahmen folgen die tatverdächtigen
gehören zu einer gruppe die sich in der
diskussion um corona und impfungen
offenbar immer mehr radikalisiert hatte
im chat geht es auch konkret um den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten michael
kretschmer
[Musik]
ermittelt wird jetzt gegen fünf männer
und eine frau ihnen wird vorgeworfen
eine schwere staatsgefährdende straftat
vorbereitet zu haben ich bin froh
darüber dass diese entschiedenheit
gezeigt worden ist und jeder soll wissen
dass man im freistaat sachsen und in der
bundesrepublik deutschland
selbstverständlich seine meinung sagen
kann aber wenn gewalt ins spiel kommt
ist schluss ist eine grenze
überschritten überschritten die von uns
nicht geduldet wird 140 beamte waren im
einsatz die unter anderem tatsächlich
auch waffen sicherstellen konnten
drohschreiben mit beigelegten
fleischstücken sind an mehrere ranghohe
politiker medien und öffentliche
institutionen verschickt worden in den
drähten roh schreiben wird ein zitat
blutiger widerstand gegen eine
impfpflicht angekündigt der staatsschutz
des berliner landeskriminalamtes
ermittelt
der bundesgerichtshof hat einen
schlussstrich unter den mammutprozess um
die rechtsextreme terrorserie des
nationalsozialistischen untergrundes
gezogen das nsu country beate schäfer
uwe bernhardt und uwe mundlos hat zehn
menschen auf dem gewissen im blickpunkt
heute nsu unterstützer andré drei von
ihm gemietete wohnmobile hatten böhnert
und mundlos bei anschlägen und
überfällen verwendet der
bundesgerichtshof bestätigte heute
andreas haftstrafe von zweieinhalb
jahren christoph schneider
damit ist das verfahren gegen andre hier
bilder vom langen nsu prozess in münchen
nun endgültig beendet
sowohl der revision des
generalbundesanwalts als auch derjenigen
des angeklagten bleibt der erfolg
versagt
die miete nach den feststellungen des
oberlandesgerichts münchen für das nsu
trio mehrfach wohnmobile an die
angemieteten fahrzeuge nutzten uwe
bernhardt und uwe mundlos dazu banken zu
überfallen und einen sprengstoffanschlag
mit einer christstollen dose in köln zu
begehen kernfrage wussten für welche
vorsätzlichen taten die wohnmobile durch
die männer genutzt wurden nein sagt das
oberlandesgericht münchen verurteilte
ihn wegen unterstützung einer
terroristischen vereinigung nicht aber
wegen unter anderem versuchte beihilfe
zum mord was eine wesentlich höhere
strafe zur folge gehabt hätte und das
ist rechtlich auch in ordnung urteilt
der bgh die nebenklage ist enttäuscht
bedauert vor allem die
aussageverweigerung von e während des
prozesses in münchen
da hat er komplett geschrieben das ist
so ein signal am besten wegdrücken am
besten schweigen und dann passiert euch
nichts und das finde ich angesichts der
tatsache dass die rechtsextremistische
gewalt weiter andauert problematisch der
große nsu komplex juristisch nunmehr
durch den bundesgerichtshof
abgeschlossen doch weiterhin
unbeantwortet bleiben fragen viele
nebenkläger bei der aufarbeitung der
mord serie
im kampf gegen die pandemie hat gestern
abend diese meldung für aufregung
gesorgt es gebe anfang nächsten jahres
zu wenig impfstoff hatte
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach der
ard gesagt heute dann größtenteils in
warnung und dies auch wichtig wenn die
bundesregierung ihre ehrgeizigen ziele
erreichen will wiener küche denn hat die
neueste entwicklung und wichtige
eckdaten zu münchen
hamburg altona heute nachmittag lange
schlange vor dem impfzentrum hier konnte
man ohne termin kommen und sich seine
impfung ab ich mache jetzt mal zehn
minuten und gucke wie schnell die
schlange vorangeht weil ich habe
eigentlich ein termin bei meiner
orthopädin der ist aber erst ende januar
dass es mir zu spät mein mann hat gerade
geguckt sonst gibt's bis januar nichts
mehr an terminen und insofern stehe ich
hier sehr zufrieden
und dann hieß es gestern plötzlich es
gebe zu wenig impfstoff für nächstes
jahr das schnelle impf tempo in gefahr
doch die ministerien reagieren und
kaufen millionen zusätzliche impfdosen
diese beschaffungen laufen bereits bei
der kommission der europäischen
kommission habe auch bei den unternehmen
selbst dem stoffe verkaufen und wir
reden über 92 millionen dosen biontech
und moderner für die wir jetzt 2,2
milliarden euro aus unserer vorsorge
mobilisieren aktuell sind 72,8 prozent
aller menschen in deutschland mindestens
einmal geimpft das sind 60,6 millionen
69,8 prozent sind vollständig geben
25,9 prozent haben schon die dritte die
auffrischungsimpfung erhalten derzeit
ungeimpft sind 27,2 prozent der menschen
also knapp 23 millionen wobei ein teil
von ihnen sich nicht impfen lassen kann
übrigens allein in den letzten zwei
wochen haben sich fast eine million
menschen erst impfen lassen und der
appell aus politik und wissenschaft
bleibt nur durch das impfen kann die
pandemie beendet werden
und der blick auf die korona zahlen
bestätigt ein ermutigenden trend das
robert koch institut meldet
51.300 1 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages
18.300 weniger als vor einer woche
453 menschen starben binnen 24 stunden
die inzidenz sinkt weiter auf 353 und
jetzt zu einem urteil das die ohnehin
schon angespannten deutsch-russischen
beziehungen noch weiter belasten wird im
sogenannten tiergarten mortis der
angeklagte heute zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt worden das gericht ist sich
sicher dass der 56 jährige russe im
august 2009 10 ein georgier erschossen
hat am helllichten tag mitten im
berliner tiergarten als erwiesen gilt
auch dass der auftrag zur tat aus moskau
kam
staatsterrorismus nannte das der
vorsitzende richter weniger über das
urteil
keine kamera erwischt im soll den mann
der hier von den richtern verurteilt
wird als bei dem quasi kopf 56 jahre alt
russe agent und mutmaßlicher mörder im
auftrag moskaus die richter sprechen
sogar von staatsterrorismus weil
russischen regierungsstellen nach
überzeugung der richter hier dafür
verantwortlich waren diesen mord in
auftrag zu geben mitten in berlins
kleinem tiergarten soll quasi kauf im
august 2009 10 einen 40 jährigen
georgier erschossen haben der schon
einige jahre in deutschland lebte der
konkrete auftraggeber ist nicht
festgestellt worden das tat opfer ist in
das visier geraten durch seine
freundschaft zum russischen staat
insbesondere durch seine teilnahme an
den kämpfen im zweiten
tschetschenienkrieg vor gericht
bestreitet der angeklagte lietz hat der
angeklagte hat insbesondere bestritten
teil des russischen sicherheitsapparates
zu sein oder ein auftrag irgendeines
sicherheitsapparates gehandelt zu haben
und dafür gibt es auch aus unserer sicht
kein einziges tragfähiges beweismittel
das urteil eine bewährungsprobe für die
neue bundesregierung und ihre
beziehungen zu moskau wir haben daher
gerade eben den botschafter russlands zu
einem gespräch einbestellt
der botschafter wurde mitgeteilt dass
zwei angehörige des diplomatischen
personals der russischen botschaft zu
unerwünschten personen erklärt werden
eine reaktion die nicht ohne russische
antwort bleiben wird
was es bedeuten kann wenn man sich gegen
die russische regierung stellt hat auch
der oppositionelle alexej nawalny
erfahren heute wurde er mit dem sacharow
preis für menschenrechte des eu
parlaments ausgezeichnet weil am
gefängnis sitzt nahm seine tochter daria
dabei na ja die auszeichnung in
straßburg entgegen sie forderte in ihrer
rede ein entschieden das auftreten der
welt gegen russlands präsident wladimir
putin
musikwünsche zur verabschiedung finden
in diesen tagen ja große beachtung auch
die der ehemaligen
bundesverteidigungsminister in annegret
kramp karrenbauer
sie hatte sich für ihren großen
zapfenstreich im bendlerblock unter
anderem für die titelmelodie aus dem
western die glorreichen sieben
entschieden
nachfolgerin von kramp karrenbauer ist
christina lambrecht von der spd
unser fußball bundesliga in arbeit
bayern münchen das ja vorzeitig
herbstmeister durch den klaren 15 0
auswärtssieg in stuttgart am vorletzten
spieltag der hinrunde
herausragender fcb-spieler gestern abend
savary drei tore selbst geschossen und
zwei für robert lewandowski vorbereitet
verriet zeigt in seiner stuttgarter
heimat was er kann liefert eine
überragende partie ab erzählt die ersten
beiden bayern tore selbst 41 und 54
minute eine erleichterung für ihn
nachdem er in der liga an sechs spielen
nicht getroffen hatte anfang an
dominiert lässt sich nicht so einfach zu
bespielen war aber im endeffekt doch in
der zweiten halbzeit nochmal gesteigert
und heute lief es einfach für die
mannschaft und für mich sie legt
anschließend für robert lewandowski aus
sowohl das 13 0 als auch das 4 0 die
bayern extrem effizient und torhungrig
den schlusspunkt setzt gabri das 5 0 die
höchste heimpleite der stuttgarter seit
1994 wie bayern feiern die
herbstmeisterschaft und jetzt schon 52
erzielte tore und
alle partien und alle tore dieses 16
spieltag sub mitternacht bei uns
ausführlich zu sehen bei zdf heute.de
und in der zdf- heute- app aus der traum
von der ersten wm medaille nach 14
jahren für die deutschen handballerinnen
im halbfinale unterlagen sie spanien
dabei führte das dhb team nach 17
starken anfangsminuten mit 7 zu 3 danach
aber immer wieder viele fehler in
angriff und verteidigung die
gastgeberinnen gewannen die oberhand am
ende eine bittere 21 zu 26-niederlage
basketball superstar scottie hat einen
neuen rekord in der nba aufgestellt beim
sieg seiner golden state warriors gegen
die new york knicks gestern abend der
ziethe curry seinen
2977 drei-punkte-wurf und überholte
damit rekordhalter ray allen der den
spitzenplatz vor zehn jahren mit
2973 drei jahren übernommen hatte
soll das war's vom sport dankeschön hat
und heute gibt es natürlich wieder
lottozahlen hier sind sie die
gewinnzahlen lauten 4 15 17 26 28 und
die superzahl ist die zwei weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
beim wetter erwartet uns morgen etwas
mehr sonnenschein mehr dazu gleich von
ist intelli um 22.15 können sie hier das
heute journal sehen mit claus kleber auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter auflockerungen gibt es in der
nacht vor allem im norden und im süden
deutschlands in der mitte viele wolken
und gelegentlich tröpfelt assist
sprühregen dazu sinken die temperaturen
auf minus vier grad an den alpen und 8
grad in schleswig-holstein morgen dann
sonnenschein vor allem richtung ostsee
und in den östlichen landesteilen und
auch im süden sonst sind wieder viele
wolken dabei und es tröpfelt wieder aus
der dichten wolkendecke bei temperaturen
von zwei grad an den alpen und 10 grad
im nordwesten die kommenden tage am
freitag gibt es im osten etwas regen
sonst hier und da auch sonnenschein bei
zwei bis zehn grad und damit ein schöner
abend